what were the biggest tech IPOs in
history although today the information
superhighway reigned supreme back in the
19th century it was all about the
railway the Union Pacific railroad
company came out of government
receivership in 1898 and issued an
unprecedented a hundred and thirty six
million dollars in stock to investors
that's almost four billion dollars in
today's money in 1956 the Eisenhower
administration began building the
interstate highway systems and that same
year henry ford ii took his
grandfather's company public raising 660
million dollars that's almost six
billion dollars in 2014 that remained
america's largest IPO until apple's in
1980 which created 300 millionaires
overnight on paper at least six years
later there was a bumper crop of tech
IPOs with microsoft landing first
followed by Oracle Sun Microsystems and
Adobe hewed global IP o's during the 90s
from germany's t-mobile and japan's NTT
paved the way for AT&T Wireless to go
public in 2000 the dot-com bubble was
about to burst
but a tnt's brand awareness and solid
financials helped it raise ten point six
billion dollars making it the fifth
largest IPO in US history but Alibaba
may soon bump that down to number six